I see.
Let's take a couple of questions from
the live chat zooming along here.
So,
um,
how should one deal with recurring
self pity and why is it so gripping?
Well,
it can be gripping for
a variety of reasons.
It can be gripping because you are,
let's see,
because you are high in neuroticism.
That's a possibility.
And A,
and why is it so gripping?
Well,
that's another potential reason.
It's hard for me to say.
Um,
let's see.
I have a,
another chapter like that.
What's it called there?
Um,
yeah,
it again,
it's rural to treat yourself like
someone you were responsible for helping.
Well,
why the hell wouldn't you pity yourself?
I mean,
people are,
life is tragic.
Everything ends in death.
Everything that you have
will be taken away from you.
You're weak and breakable and prone to
fits of impulsivity and malevolence.
How could you not have self pity?
Well,
that's really the answer,
but,
but the next answer is,
yeah,
well,
despite that,
it's not good enough.
You have to rise above all that even
though you have every reason for it.
That's the thing that's so paradoxical
is you have to rise above it even though
you have every reason for it.
And part of the reason you have to
rise above it is because if you don't,
it makes everything worse.
You and everything else and being itself.
And so it's gripping because well,
it does grip you,
you know,
malevolence and tragedy
and vulnerability and,
and mortality.
They're gripping.
And I would say,
well,
you have to find something that's
even more gripping than that.
And I would say the most,
the thing that's most gripping,
the only thing that's more gripping
than that in true and truth,
is to live a good life,
to live the best life you possibly can,
to live a life that's so noble that
all of those things are justifiable.
Yuri,
l three 33 he says,
JP thinks he is a monster.
L U.
L I didn't know what l u l means,
but I don't actually think I'm a monster.
There's a difference between thinking
you're a monster and knowing you're a
monster.